bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france
ma première question est ce qu'il est
possible de se protéger contre ce type
d'attaqués virtuelles si oui comment
pour se protéger contre ce processus
était passé quasiment imparable puisque
il se connecte automatiquement sur une
fausse adresse va sur une fausse
antennes relais et à partir du moment où
vous connecter sur sur internet il
télécharge automatiquement le malware
donc c'est imparable plus en plus
ensuite des solutions antivirales que
l'on peut avoir
ne réussissent pas à la nier
et il disparaît quand l'attaquant a
décidé de le faire disparaître
justement comment commencer cibles
peuvent se rendre compte qu'elles sont
sur écoute ce qu'il ya un moyen de
savoir a priori le seul cas où on est
une réelle documentation c'est celui du
théâtre des osses donc le premier le
patron d'amazon qui avait remarqué de sa
consommation à son téléchargement était
passé de quelques centaines de médailles
mégaoctets à plus de 500 qui est de
pardon de quelques centaines de kilo
octet à plus de 500 mégaoctets par jour
donc cette consommation l'alerté et puis
s'est aperçu que lui il a les moyens
l'itc
c'est juste ans il n'y avait pas
forcément par exemple sur son téléphone
est ce qu'il ya des des signaux est ce
qu'il ya des alertes par exemple je sais
pas des grésillements ou non non là on
est sur un outil qui ciblent des
personnalités bien décidé qu'on me
l'avait dit dans votre dans votre sujet
il ya quelques centaines voire quelques
milliers de l'adresse ou de ses deux
numéros de téléphone ou de noms de
domaines qui ont été ciblés
on est vraiment sûr du sur mesure
on n'est pas sur quelque chose qui
surveille n'importe qui n'importe quand
comme seuls les états savent le faire là
on est sur une solution qui est
disponible pour des états mais a priori
d'après les mêmes chiffres que vous vous
avez utilisé pour monter votre votre
dossier il n'y aurait qu'une dizaine
d'états
il utilise pour faire du renseignement
sur des objectifs réellement politique
je pense alain 12 et au pakistan
je pense les pays européens dans le
cadre du terrorisme la lituanie la
pologne avec leurs problèmes vis-à-vis
de la russie
mais le plus important sur les 45 états
qui ont été plus ou moins identifiés
ayant cette solution qui est utilisé on
aurait 36 autres clients et c'est aux
autres clients sont des clients privés
parce que vous pouvez acheter cette
solution pour une centaine de milliers
d'euros voire aller jusqu'à quelques
millions d'euros par smartphone bien
qu'on est sur une solution qui est
vraiment sur deux sur mesure où pour
surveiller des opposants politiques pour
surveiller des diplomates
et pourquoi pas pour surveiller des
concurrents économiques
l'entreprise israélienne un vaisseau
avec les licences pour ce logiciel était
uniquement accordé au gouvernement pour
lutter contre le crime et le terrorisme
comment expliquer par exemple quand on
voit les 6 me soit tous des membres de
l'opposition politique
quand vous avez un outil pour surveiller
des opposants pas pour surveiller est
question de cybercrime ou de terrorisme
c'est tout simple de brancher des gens
qui sont des opposants politiques
le burkina faso le mali ou encore le
maroc sont également cités dans
l'article du monde pour avoir utiliser
ce logiciel d'espionnage
il ya aussi un autre exemple entre 2010
et 2012 au moins les services des états
unis ont écouté trois présidents de la
république française
est ce que finalement c'est une pratique
qui se répand de plus en plus c'est ce
que les pratiques sont différentes
également il ya deux choses qu'il faut
bien prendre en compte les présidents de
la république française qui ont été
écoutés par les services de
renseignement américains le sont par le
système que l'on a connu dans les années
90 a appelé l'échelon et que et noir
semaines a encore remis une couche avec
des produits mais c'est toujours le même
système
c'est les files qui écoute le monde
entier lors les sur des solutions qui
sont purement étatique aprem avec
pegasus
il existe également une solution autre
qui s'appelle galileo on est dans des
solutions sont disponibles pour ceux qui
ont les moyens de se les payer
il n'est pas étonnant de voir les
monarchies pétrolières dans le feu de la
péninsule arabique les utiliser après on
est sur des pays qui sont comme vous le
savez démocratie tout à fait moderne et
respectueuse des droits de l'homme
donc il faut pas déconner ils
surveillent les rênes à revoir dans la
question en quelques mots dans le cas de
ce logiciel qui était prévu initialement
pour lutter contre le terrorisme
où est la limite entre la surveillance
est justement l'intrusion quand on est
dans des pays où il n'ya pas de respect
de la vie privée il n'y a pas de limite
et on voit que ce sont des % des pays
inutile
pegasus sont situés soit dans le monde
arabe soit en asie aussi bien centrale
que du sud est soit en afrique avec
trois pays qui sont les organisateurs de
ceux de ce système c'est l'arabie
saoudite c'est la turquie
et c'est israël qui vend la solution
très bien merci
gérald à arbois pour toutes ces
précisions
je rappelle que vous êtes chercheur
associé à la sorbonne spécialisée elle
sur les services de renseignement